in Google cloud platform you'll need a
billing account to pay for any services
you use let's walk through how to manage
and set up permissions for a billing
account to start we'll need to go to the
page for the billing account on the left
hand side
choose billing and then click on manage
billing accounts to see a list of all
your billing accounts here you can see
each billing account as well as the
number of projects associated with each
one you can click on an account to see
more detailed information about the
account and get an overview of the costs
to manage this billing account click on
manage in the top right from here we can
see the Associated projects and manage
permissions in order to make sure others
can see costs for this billing account
let's show how to add a user click Add
member and type in a user's email
address then choose a role the default
roles for billing accounts are viewers
users and admins billing account viewers
have access to see the costs associated
with the billing account while users can
view costs and add projects to the
billing account billing account
administrators can do all of that plus
manage the billing account itself such
as assigning permissions managing export
settings or contacting billing support
for this example let's add someone as a
billing account viewer so that they can
see the costs for this billing account
and all the associated projects without
being able to associate any additional
projects you can also add a group and
assign roles so that all users in the
group will share the same permissions
users and groups can be managed via G
suite or cloud identity if you want a
user to only see the costs for
individual projects rather than all the
costs for projects attached to a billing
account give them the project viewer
role on each project rather than billing
account viewer on the billing account
similarly for all permissions you can
even assign a group to the project
viewer role and then add users to that
group now if you're a billing account
user or admin on a billing account
you'll be able to link that billing
account to a project when you create it
if you want to change the billing
account for a project head back to the
billing account management page and
click on the options menu next to that
project choose
change billing and then pick a new
billing account you can also disable
billing for a project which will shut
down all paid resources for that project
so be careful now you should be able to
start managing your billing account and
assigning permissions to them